in der tat das geht jeden bürger an was
jetzt hier die nächsten fünf tage im
parlament passiert am freitag dann die
schlussabstimmung im saarland hat das
gesagt 362 milliarden euro stehen für
den haushalt 2020 zur verfügung das sind
knapp 6 milliarden mehr als im laufenden
jahr und 42,9 milliarden investitionen
das ein rekord investitionshaushalt und
in estland hat das auch erwin zum
siebten mal in folge wird die schwarze
null gehalten die 15 stündige
bereinigungssitzung des
haushaltsausschusses brachte noch einige
zugaben 1,66 milliarden hat man noch
obendrauf gelegt so dass man dann bei
diesen 362 milliarden gelandet ist und
darüber will ich jetzt leben mit meinen
gästen ich begrüße johannes kahrs den
haushaltspolitischen sprecher der
spd-bundestagsfraktion und peter
böhringer in der gleichen funktion und
zusätzlich vorsitzender des
haushaltsausschusses der afg sozusagen
haushaltspolitischer sprecher der hfg
und vorsitzender des
haushaltsausschusses richtig sein
herr k s ist ja eine entscheidende woche
für olaf scholz nicht nur der haushalt
den er hier durchbringen will die
schwarze null hat sein konkurrent gesagt
herr walter borjans sei völliger unsinn
und fresken beide stehen ja zur wahl
gegen olaf scholz und frau gallwitz am
samstag werden wir wissen wer dann
parteichef der spd werden soll
frau essen hat gesagt der finanzminister
spricht mit seiner art und weise die spd
er ist zu kompromissbereit das sind
schwere vorwürfe
naja ich halte sich für schwere vorwürfe
ich halte es für unfug
im kern ist es so dass olaf scholz hier
sehr viel durchsetzt mit der spd
also sie können sich das ja angucken
inhaltlich sowohl der koalitionsvertrag
auch als auch das was hier beschlossen
wird schon sehr sozialdemokratisch
deswegen hat die cdu ja intern gerade so
viel ärger und wenn man bei steigenden
steuereinnahmen
gleichzeitig keine neuen schulden macht
finde ich das ganze in ordnung man muss
auch mal mit dem geld auskommen was man
hat und natürlich kann man sich immer
geld leihen und es gibt immer dinge die
man vielleicht gerne hätte aber
irgendwer wird es am ende bezahlen
müssen und unser problem ist gar nicht
so dass wir um
mehr geld brauchen unser problem ist
dass das vorhandene geld nicht abfließt
weil die behörden nicht so funktionieren
weil wir überall nicht genug beamte
haben weil das baurecht zu kompliziert
und zu langwierig ist weil wir viel zu
viele probleme auch rechtlicher natur
haben wir wieder geklagt wird weil wir
nicht genug unternehmen haben heißt alle
lang ende
ich glaube das ist ein guter haushalt
ein guter kompromiss so wie das in der
demokratie und einer koalition zu sein
hat der bürger das ist vor allen dingen
ein haushalt haushalt von
bundesfinanzminister scholz jahr zum
zehnten mal die schwarze null beinhaltet
welchen anteil hat denn eigentlich die
bundesregierung daran dass diese
schwarze null gehalten ist
es ist ja nicht der siebte ausgeglichene
aussage von olaf scholz aber gut
insgesamt wird es als siebter haushalt
bezeichnet wir sehen das nicht so ich
habe das schon wiederholt er im haus
gesagt es ist keine schwarze null
insofern muss die spd erlich gesagt auch
nicht darüber streiten ob es eine chance
ergeben sollte oder nicht weil es gibt
sie heute auch nicht das hat
verschiedene gründe sind viele risiken
nicht eingestellt die man einstellen
könnte und auch müsste sind auch auf der
ausgabenseite einige dinge nicht sauber
wenn wir die etikettenschwindel
gearbeitet und ja also auf der
investitionsseite was sie immer schon
gesagt haben der aufwuchs der am ende
herauskam relativ kleine muss ich noch
dazu sagen ist ausschließlich der klima
ideologie geschuldet und das ist keine
investition in deutschland sein das ist
sozusagen eine in die planetarische
zukunft extrem wolkig ja und weil wir
das als investition sieht in deutschland
gar ja gut dann haben wir auf wuchs aber
eigentlich ist das kein investiver
aufbruch sind sofern auch kein wirklich
seriöse haushalt gras wir müssen das
noch mal dem zuschauer erklären diese
schwarze null also keine neue
schuldenaufnahme da sagt die opposition
unisono dies ein rechentrick und wenn
man mal hinschaut dann ist dass der
geschmackssinn rechentrick ist denn man
olaf scholz in dem fall nimmt geld 10,6
milliarden aus der flüchtlings kasse
quasi und er hat glück dass die
neuverschuldung nicht irgendwie höher
ist sondern dass wir nicht in der
rezession die stolper sind also er hat
noch glaube 4 milliarden mehr als
ursprünglich geplant hatte also das
zusammen hat ihn gerettet über die
schwarze null ist das jetzt ein
haushalts trick also ich glaube dass die
vernünftige haushaltsführung wenn man
mehr geld hat als man braucht licht man
was zurück kennt man von sich selber
auch
und wenn man dann wieder was braucht
dann nimmt man aus der eigenen rücklage
raus ist auch kein trick soll das ist
ganz normales verfahren wenn ich sparen
habe ich mir irgendwann was leisten kann
ist das auch entsprechend
das heißt wir haben eine
haushaltspolitik die solide ist auf der
anderen seite haben wir aber auch
dadurch dass sie in den letzten jahren
viel mehr geld ausgegeben investiert
haben und auch den bürgern über 15
milliarden zurück gegeben haben im
nächsten jahren werden dass noch 20 und
noch mehr
dadurch dass der bürger das geld zurück
gekriegt hat hat er ja auch geld
investiert das heißt die
binnenkonjunktur die wir haben wird ja
auch viel durch diesen haushalt durch
diese bundesregierung mitgetragen
wir haben probleme beim export kennt
jeder selber nicht ein bisschen am brett
an trump an den chinesen und all den
gastronom ist aber in deutschland die
binnennachfrage brummt und läuft und das
liegt eben auch an der bundesregierung
die viel dafür tut das wiederum führt zu
den überschüssen von denen wir dann auch
keine neue schulden machen müssen wir
würden ja da gibt es also eine kasse für
die flüchtlinge vielleicht wird das ja
noch gebraucht im moment nicht da liegt
35 milliarden drin oder stolzen im 10,6
milliarden sie als haushälter ich muss
mal fragen wo sind die eigentlich
veranschlagt es gibt ja noch mehrere
solcher kassen und ich finde die
eigentlich im haushaltsentwurf nicht wo
werden die verbucht
gut die eben von ihnen erwähnte kasse
gibt es tatsächlich sie heißt asyl
rücklage sie wird nicht dafür verwendet
es ist eine globale rücklage dieser vier
jahren aufgebaut wurde inzwischen
weitgehend sachfremd verwendet wird und
auch gar nicht erst hätte aufgebaut
werden dürfen
das gab es noch nie in der geschichte
der bundesrepublik dass auf dieser ebene
eine rücklage erstellt wurde
insofern der bürger außerdem gesagt
hätte hat das zurückbekommen ein er
hätte das geld zurück bekommen müssen er
hat aber nicht zurückbekommen schon seit
vier jahren das ist das vierte
haushaltsjahr in dem das nicht geschieht
und ja deshalb wird diese kasse immer
größeren größe und das ist ganz klar ich
weiß jetzt schon dass du den sich 20 21
11 21 mit dem letzten haushalt von
opfern
diese kasse komplett aufgebraucht sein
wird
es gibt andere rücklagen die sind zum
teil auch nicht konsolidiert auf der ek
es ist nicht wirklich voll integriert
also ist das sei das ist der klimafonds
der jetzt inzwischen immer wichtiger
wird also darauf nicht wirklich da
spielt jetzt die musik ab sofort
lagen bislang 7 milliarden das wird
jetzt deutlich mehr werden das
wirtschaft grund dieser co2 ideologie
und es ist eine ideologie wird ist jetzt
immer mehr und auch das ist nicht
konsolidiert also das ist auch aus
ätherischen problem wenn man das nicht
macht es gibt seit urzeiten den
investitions und tilgungsfonds der seite
aus der finanzkrise noch stammt ja auch
nicht abbezahlt wurde auch nicht
integriert ist das ist alles altlasten
durch und durch unseriöse auf der
südseite des ja eben genannten
migrations seite gibt es auch dinge die
nicht sauber gerechnet sind das gibt's
verschiebebahnhöfe vieles wird was
eigentlich migrationskosten sind im
sozialetat abgebildet kosten der
unterkunft für abgelehnte asylbewerber
oder auch hartz 4 für abgelehnte
asylbewerber die es gar nicht ausgeben
dürfte habe ich immer noch nicht ganz
verstanden wo die verbucht sind aber sie
haben es ja ebenso anschaulich gesagt
wenn ich zu hause noch geld habe
irgendwo liegen habe dann kann ich damit
ja meine momentane schulden die
vielleicht auflaufen dann tilgen
da kann man nur sagen 19 milliarden
investitionen zum beispiel sind im
vergangenen jahr nicht abgerufen worden
das haben sie schon angesprochen das
problem dass dort auch zum beispiel beim
planungsrecht anders gehandelt werden
müsste es gibt ein sondervermögen von 20
milliarden
das ist geld was immer mal übrig
geblieben ist die anderen haushalte es
gibt ja viele vermögens töpfe und er
fragt man sich schon warum konnte der
soli nicht für alle menschen abgeschafft
wenn das geld ist doch da also der soli
ist abgeschafft worden für 90 prozent
der deutschen das heißt für diejenigen
die den steuern gezahlt haben sind 90
prozent der menschen jetzt vom soli
befreit das haben wir im
koalitionsvertrag soll vereinbart
und wir haben auch gesagt bei denen die
sehr viel verdienen das schaffen wir das
nicht ab das geld brauchen wir auch
ansonsten wäre die summe die wir hier
brauchen um den haushalt auf null zu
bringen kommt zu halten dass investieren
wir zum beispiel im bereich familie im
bereich gesundheit im bereich renten was
ich für vernünftig halte das ist auch
vernünftig aber
die leute die so viel geld bezahlen in
der steuersystem da sind ja gerade die
oberen zehn prozent die für 50 prozent
auch einzahlen
sie müssen doch erstmal diese steuer
abschaffen denn das ist auch gar nicht
sicher ob dieser soli diese
weiterzahlung vom
bundesverfassungsgericht standhält dann
können sie ja eventuell eine neue steuer
einführen zu müssen schwierig mit dem
koalitionspartner aber das wäre doch
viel logischer also im kern ist es so
dass das verfassungsgericht macht weist
kein mensch vor gericht und auf hoher
see ist man in gottes hand ansonsten ist
es so dass wir gerade auch als
sozialdemokraten darauf gedrungen haben
dass wir diese zehn prozent also die
hälfte des soli in das steuersystem
überführen
dann hätten wir das entsprechend so
aufgeteilt dass die leute dann weiter
diese steuern zahlen
also die zehn prozent es wäre aber nicht
mehr der name dagewesen
solidaritätszuschlags oder das wäre ins
normale steuersystem überführt worden
das hätte ich für vernünftig gehalten
das haben wir der union drei mal
vorgeschlagen die wollte das nicht
im kern ist es richtig dass man die
schultern die stärker sind belastet
damit sie das weiter zahlen wir haben in
diesem land viele ausgaben die wir haben
zum beispiel auch bei der grundrente die
finanziert werden müssen
und ehrlich gesagt am ende glaube ich
haben wir das mit der union sehr gut
verhandelt dass die union das jetzt
nicht mehr so schön findet das mag so
sein aber beschlusslage ist es bis
september 21 übrigens auch ein beispiel
das urlaubs schaut sich durchgesetzt hat
so viel nur in richtung frau eske aber
nochmal also besser verdienen da ist man
bei der spd schon mit 73.000 euro
jahresgehalt
und es wird immer kritisiert auch von
der union zum beispiel dass vor allem
der mittelstand dort massiv betroffen
ist
dennoch das argument starke schultern
können mehr tragen
wir sind auch mit der stanz freundlich
wir haben übrigens die auf den aufwuchs
einer ganz wenigen positiven punkt der
im haushalt bei der
mittelstandsförderung auch mitgetragen
die grundrente die hasen genannt hat ein
wahlkampfschlager in eigener sache
spd-intern von olaf scholz ist weder
koalitionsintern
programm noch ist er finanziert sie ist
findet sich mit keinem keine zahl im
haushalt auch nicht in der
mittelfristigen finanzplanung und was
den soli angeht man kann ja nicht
einfach darüber hinweggehen man ist auf
hoher see beim verfassungsgericht das
ist recht sicher dass diese zahlungen
zurück erstattet werden müssen von
fiskus allerdings nicht mehr von einem
fiskus unter der leitung von olaf scholz
sondern dann lange jahre später das ist
der politik nach dem motto nach uns die
sintflut 55 milliarden ist das risiko
über die nächsten vier jahre
und ja oder volkswirt ist nicht mehr
zurückzahlen müssen das macht es halt
hochgradig unseriös denn das geld wird
heute vor frühstück übrigens genauso wie
diverse zins tricks bei denen man heute
cook milliardenschwere einnahmen
generiert indem man zu hohe zins kupons
aus ausgibt und dann späteren
steuerzahler generationen zu hohe zinsen
auf die staatsschuld zahlen lässt das
ist alles nichts in seriös und wirt
gemacht es wird alles zusammengekratzt
mit dem ziel 2021 weil jeder weiß dass
danach ein anderer finanzminister kommen
grundrente steht tatsächlich hier nicht
im wurf drin da soll die
finanztransaktionssteuer die anderthalb
milliarden wie es mindestens kosten wird
aufbringen
die gibt es ja noch gar nicht und da
gibt es jetzt offensichtlich demnächst
auch wieder ein streit zwischen den
koalitionspartnern denen die union hat
auf ihrem parteitag die cdu hat auf
ihrem parteitag gesagt nur wenn es
europaweit eingeführt wird da machen wir
das mit
ich verstehe dass die union an einigen
ecken jetzt probiert die grundrente
wieder aufzurütteln
1,5 millionen menschen sollen 850 euro
im monat kriegen wenn das reichtümer
sind oder wie eben die afg sagt
wahlkampfschlager
man sollte man mit diesen 1,5 millionen
menschen reden und das war mit 850 euro
im monat klar kommt ist sowieso sehr
schwierig ich persönlich glaube dass man
die grundrente sowieso höher ansetzen
muss aber mehr war mit der cdu/csu im
moment nicht machbar
wir werden die grundrente umsetzen und
eine anmerkung zur afg haben wir nochmal
gestattet dass die afg hier für die
reichen kämpft und für entlastung der
reichen passt ganz zu ihrem profil
ihnen geht es nicht um die rentner den
sozial schwachen und den armen oder die
menschen im osten hin geht es darum die
reichen zu entlasten
damit sind sie ganz in der tradition
anderer rechtsradikaler parteien vor ihm
ja also das sollten wir jetzt hier nicht
weiter als diskutieren wir bringen das
bringt nichts wie ich will sie anders
fragen diese 19 milliarden die eben
schon mal angesprochen
wagen die nicht abgerufen wurden diese
investition da wundert man sich ja schon
als bundesbürger und fragt sich das ist
ja ein kernproblem warum fordert die
politik immer mehr geld von den bürgern
über steuern und anderes wenn sie doch
diese investition für die sich die
bundesregierung jetzt auch feiern lässt
rekordinvestitionen gar nicht an den
mann bringt das kann doch nicht nur an
den planungsverfahren liegen und wenn es
daran liegt hätte das doch längst
geändert werden müssen ja das ist
eigentlich eine klare frage die sie
wirklich an die regierung stellen denn
das ist ein dauer versäumnis dass die
gelder nicht abgerufen werden die ja
alle auf projekten beruhen die die
regierungen selbst ins leben gerufen hat
und von einer verwaltung administriert
werden ja auch die regierung verwaltet
und regiert das ist keine frage die
opposition zu beantworten hat wir nehmen
zur kenntnis dass nicht alles abfließt
das stimmt unschön ganz klar in
regierungs problem und was die
grundrente angeht und den kleinen mann
ja also in der tat gibt es ein
altersarmut problem die ursache dafür
ist in vielen vielen fällen der 0 und
negativzins von dem die regierung massiv
profitiert sonst hätte sie nämlich nicht
ansatzweise auch nur nominal einen
ausgeglichenen haushalt das würde aber
nicht adressiert stattdessen dort hat
man in symptomen rum wie in diesem fall
der rente für tatsächlich arme das kann
man ja machen aber dann nicht über die
finanztransaktionssteuer
gegenfinanzieren die tatsächlich auch
wiederum unsozial ist weil gerade die
kleinen aktien sprache die in aktien
sparen was man heutzutage tun musste
anleihe nichts mehr abwerfen und ihre
rente auf dem wege irgendwie sichern
wollen diese jetzt auch noch
finanztransaktionssteuer zahlen die
heißt es sollte euch aktien spaß steuer
heißen und die großen institutionellen
derivate zucker und die internationalen
hedgefonds die zahlen nämlich just diese
steuer nicht das ist dann spd politik
für den kleinen mann
wenn ich wenn ich jetzt noch mal auf die
frage kommen darf schwarze null und wir
haben auf der anderen seite die
schuldenbremse leider kommt von den
grünen interessanter vorschlag die
schuldenbremse besagt 0,35 prozent des
bip kann der bund im notfall aufnehmen
das hat die bundesregierung jetzt nicht
gewollt aber es wird immer wieder von
allen seiten kritisiert
es muss mehr geld in verschiedene
systeme fließen bei den grünen ist vor
allem der klimafonds der völlig
unterfinanziert ist nach deren meinung
und deswegen schlagen sie vor
ein prozent verschuldung und die dann
auch einzugehen was halten sie davon
es gibt immer gute gründe neue schulden
zu machen es gibt immer gute gründe das
geld des steuerzahlers mehr auszugeben
sie haben ja eben selber festgestellt
dass es viele milliarden gibt an
investitionen die wir getätigt haben die
nicht abfließen da jetzt noch mehr
milliarden drauf zu setzen scheint ja
nicht wirklich dass rätsels lösung zu
sein sondern das was wir gemacht haben
es wir haben 6900 stellen beim bund
beschlossen damit wir mehr bau prüfer
haben damit wir mehr ingenieure vor ort
haben damit wir mehr leute haben die
diese vorhaben auch um und durchsetzen
wir machen jetzt eine änderung im
baurecht wir beschleunigen bauverfahren
und ich glaube dass es jetzt erstmal
darum geht das geld was wir einsetzen
auch umzusetzen damit der bürger dass
auch merkt sowohl in straßen eisenbahn
autobahn und wohnung und deswegen glaube
ich es gibt viele gute gründe mehr geld
irgendwo rauszuhauen immer bestimmt die
grünen können das ganz besonders gut
aber wenn schon das geld nicht abfließt
was wir haben dann macht das keinen sinn
und daher nun sowohl die afg gerne
schulden macht die grünen gerne schulden
machen und andere finde ich es mal
vernünftig dass es parteien gibt
dirigieren die mit dem geld der
steuerzahler auskommen würden ja ganz
kurz nur die schwarze null ist ja kein
selbstzweck damit erreicht man ja
einiges auch wenn die jetzt getrickst es
würden sie die aufgeben wenn sie
regieren würden tschuldigung ich nehme
es zurück nicht getrickst sondern wenn
sie anders finanziert wird als es
zunächst erscheint würden sie die
beibehalten wenn sie regieren würden
würden sie auch wenn die kommenden
steuerzeiten sehr mager werden bei der
ideologie getriebenen rezession die auf
uns zurollt wir würden sie nicht
aufgeben
es gibt genügend spielraum in diesem
haushalt das noch auszugleichen
ich gebe zu dass es
betriebswirtschaftlich reizvoll ist bei
einem nullzins umfeld mehr schulden
aufzunehmen dem auf 100 jahre machen
könnte nur diese regierung der sollte
mal ganz sicher nicht mehr spielgeld für
ihr ideologisches ideologischen projekte
geben deshalb würden wir sie ganz sicher
nicht aufgeben